oh my gosh 2022 has been one of my
favorite years in Pentatonix ever it's
been so much fun and then we just kind
of nominated for a Grammy I got engaged
yes so much exciting stuff we have
babies on the road now we have a new
single with Meghan Trainor that we're
really stoked about and it's climbing
the charts it's just it's been a great
holiday surreal
congratulations on the engagement who
was more emotional yourself or your
partner he was more emotional when it
happened he was just bawling but we were
both crying how did you know that they
were the one I do pretty like early on
that Mark was the one for me
we mentioned babies on the road so who
in the group is the best diaper changer
probably Kirsten or Kevin because
they're the new parents well you put
yourself up to change diapers when
necessary if somebody's in a pinch and
they're like please it's I will never
ask you for anything again just change
this diaper one time I'll be like yeah
of course one time just once
Meghan Trainor is such a force and now
you have this beautiful video together
for kid on Christmas here to kick us off
with a festive little number Meghan
Trainor and Pentatonix take it away it's
always so fun to do do like a themed
video the whole 70s moment and just
working with Megan in general is so
inspiring and amazing
also in the studio she's engineering the
session herself she's writing the music
and so it's been cool working with her